so it's nearing the end of the year and
i feel like this is the time that i
start reflecting on life and my top tech
of 2021 and i have tested out a lot of
tech this year but this is actually one
of the things that i have really been
enjoying i would even say that this is
in my top tech of 2021 list this is the
next base 622 gw dash cam a huge thank
you to nexspace for partnering with me
on this video i'm actually really
excited about this because i have been
using this over the past few months
testing it out and reviewing it and
honestly my entire perspective on dash
cams changed the first day that i
mounted this in my car to test it out
there are so many knock-off unreliable
dash cams in the market and i've just
been so hesitant because i've tried so
many of these before and it wasn't until
i looked at the footage of this that it
actually just blew my mind
[Music]
go
a lot of these other cameras make a lot
of different claims about having really
great quality being 4k but a lot of
times after i look at the footage i
might as well have just mounted a potato
in the front of my car and just like
that's it just like cool potato actual
potato quality but this has a really
amazing 4k quality video with really
impressive image stabilization it also
has a polarizer to reduce the glare
especially when you're driving in
various sunny conditions this is super
helpful it also can embed the data into
the footage of your speed your distance
your gps and more and the footage from
it is actually so great that i can
actually use this in my youtube videos i
really love that this has an emergency
sos so it's able to detect if i were to
get into a crash and i'm unresponsive
and it's great because this is always
recording when i'm in the car so i
always feel like i have this added
benefit of safety now you guys might
have seen a few months ago that i had my
rental car broken into when i was in
hawaii and this was so traumatic because
i've actually never had this happen to
me before and just to come back and see
a car window smashed and my items gone
was just it was it was shocking if i
would have had this installed with the
intelligent parking mode enabled there's
a really good chance that i could have
caught the person who did this i may
have even been able to get their license
plate and then i would have had so much
more information to give to the police i
absolutely love this feature and it's
really cool because also if somebody
bumps your car or hits it it will
automatically turn on and start
recording what happened now my friends
as a redemption i just recently went
back to hawaii for a conference and do
you know what i did oh you better
believe it i brought this whole setup
we're about to get into the unboxing of
this so that i can show you guys
everything that comes in the box but i
really wanted to give you kind of like
this intro and why i think this is so
cool before we really get into what is
in the box so like i said redemption and
i did not want to run into the situation
that had happened previously when i was
there so i brought this with me and kept
it in the rental car and not only did i
do this for the benefits of possibly
catching another car breaking criminal
but there was so much beautiful scenery
and i was able to capture that one of
the things that i'm most impressed with
is how this is able to lock key moments
that were captured and then it will
record over any old unimportant footage
so you'll never have a full sd card also
this is kind of cool by having a dash
cam you can most likely get a discount
on your insurance if you have one of
these installed in your car so if you do
have one of these or you plan on getting
one definitely check with your insurance
company and see if this is a possibility
also since getting this i did get a new
car and i did get a tesla and of course
yes it does have the built-in camera and
it has recording software it has the
sentry mode but honestly this thing
integrates so well with the iphone and
the interface is so incredible you can
actually view all of the footage that is
recorded you can connect to this
directly you can scrub through you can
save and honestly that is something that
i really really like so i think you guys
get the gist this thing is awesome and
i'm super excited about it i would love
to hear from you guys though do you have
any experiences with dash cams do you
have one of the next base dash cams i
would love to hear in the comments below
but now
this video is basically just getting
started let's hop into the unboxing so i
can show you guys everything that this
comes with and all of the really cool
accessory options that you have this is
the next base 622 gw dash cam now i
didn't realize how exciting a dash cam
was until i took this on a road trip to
vegas it has all kinds of intelligent
features but honestly as a vlogger and
somebody who was always capturing
content this actually will record a 4k
video and what's even more exciting is
it's modular okay this is cool check
this out so i can actually attach this
rear view camera and i can not only
record in front of me but i can also
record inside of the cabin and inside of
the app you can go through and there's
all kinds of customization settings this
has so many fun features not only for
safety but like for content creators
this is amazing 4k it also has digital
image stabilization which is really
impressive so to really make everything
work you're going to need one of these
this is the actual dash cam itself like
i said shoots in 4k
what
the crazy thing is i've already unboxed
this used it but i'm doing this unboxing
in like a whole nother light because
i've already used this and i know how
incredible it is then i'm even more
excited unboxing it now than i was the
first time
we've got some instructions
having the alexa integration is actually
really cool too
here is the dash cam does have a touch
screen they do recommend charging it for
two full hours before you actually do
use it
and this
lets you attach this to
the click and go mount this is actually
pretty awesome because you can just wire
this directly to your car and then you
don't have to have any wires directly
connected to this oh my gosh so many
little goodies
they also supply you with your adapter
for the car so you can keep that fully
charged they also give you some sticky
mount options
so here's everything that comes in the
box you have our mounts and our power
and of course you have the actual dash
cam which makes everything happen
i got our usb power up here and this is
a little hdmi port so you just connect
that right here and that'll give you the
reverse image so you'll be able to film
yourself or whatever is happening inside
of your car this was so fun because it
was filming outside the window and then
jenna and i were both inside are you
going to speed limit jenna yeah because
if you're not we're all going to know
because this has the speed limit burned
into it you can turn it on or off it
also has gps overlay
and it's kind of cool that's really cool
i mean that's i feel like having this
like if something does
happen like this is evidence it is this
is indisputable evidence the evidence is
here and jenna is going one mile over
the speed limit so next we have the rear
window camera and this actually comes
with a very long cable look at this
super long cable and our little rear
window mount it's really cute this was
so much fun on our road trip because it
really did give us sort of like this
added camera angle that we normally
wouldn't have had i was honestly so
impressed not only with the video
quality but the possibilities of this
for various scenarios for safety on the
road if you get into an accident or you
witness an accident and one of the
really cool things that i like a lot
about it is you can connect it to your
phone and you can actually view the
footage on the app you can also export
footage from there and you can change
various settings and i'm such a huge fan
of the app and it's really great that
that integrates so well with this so
this is where we go that's where we go
dash cam recording
we've got the speed on now baby
[Music]
wow
is that a ball look there's a wall do
you want to go to the mall
i forgot my shoes
[Music]
am i getting whistled i don't know
okay
keys
well we freaking made it well thank you
guys so much for watching i hope you
guys enjoyed this little look at the
next base dash cam this thing is
honestly so impressive and i'm so
excited that i got a chance to check
this out and show it to you guys i'll
put a link in the description where you
can learn more or get your own and i
look forward to seeing what you guys
think if you already have one of these
please leave some comments below i'd
love to hear from you if you guys
haven't subscribed already do hit the
subscribe button and hit the bell so
you'll be notified when i post new
videos and as always i'll see you guys
in the next video
[Music]